all right give us the details about Katy
Perry five-year deal what can we expect
oh I think it's gonna be a blockbuster I
mean we're looking to set obviously new
records for glue as a company new
revenue records I think for an
individual title hopefully with her we
think that obviously she'll do amazing
things for Glu's results in the first
quarter she launches but also the years
subsequent to that so she is the first
game for us in the music category we
consider this to be distinct from
obviously the reality space that Kim
pioneered and we'll look to follow this
up with probably other talent in and
around the music sector but also the
sport space is one we're actually
looking at next alright Nicola as you
put together your roster of stars and
wonder gives you news that Kim
Kardashian game is an example to explain
to people exactly what is it that
happens that allows for this transfer of
money how does it work well the game is
a free-to-play title and what that means
is that we're making all of our money
off of advertising and micro
transactions in the game so only about
5% of people pay although everyone sees
ads and we run a very unique partnership
with our talent so we like people like
Katy Perry who's incredibly hands-on
attention to detail oriented so is Kim
and we're going to build games out that
are unique to their brand unique to
their aspirational fanbase and really
that tap into the the sheer size of
these audiences I mean Katy Perry has
over a hundred and seventy million
social followers now only a hundred and
eighteen million people
watch the Super Bowl halftime show she
put on that was phenomenal but obviously
I feel that I have a five year Superbowl
commercial in partnership with Katy
through this game now Niccolo as you
build out this roster of stars and they
see the amount of money that you make
because of their association with you
what about their demands for money well
they have a very generous participation
and that's something that's confidential
instead of me it's a meaningful you know
minority of the revenue ultimately they
recognize how unique glues value
proposition is so you know there have
been dozens and dozens of celebrity
games attempted in the past five years
on Facebook Android iOS etc we are the
only person that has come up with a
formula and these transmedia
partnerships that is not only critically
successful but commercially successful
so to give you some numbers you know
Kim's game is typically the top ten
grossing I think the second-best
celebrity game was something Lindsay
Lohan did that didn't even break
something like eight hundred and eighty
four grossing there been dozens of other
celebrity games it didn't break the top
thousand grossing so we have a unique
set of competencies we invest dozens of
people in these titles for years and
years of time and ultimately we feel we
have this celebrity platform and
partnership not only pioneered by us but
also the leading expertise is all at
glue